how to make youtube videos so i got a
great question for one of my
youtube viewers jeffrey who wrote in
love you guys he said great videos do
you use a computer a camera or what what
about software this is a great question
when i get uh asked a lot on the channel
every couple months or so i end up doing
a new video talking about the tools that
i'm using
so
i'm a big believer not spending money
till i'm making money i hate spending
money until i'm making money and that
applies to everything because i could
have said hey you know what i want to
make youtube videos i'm going to go and
buy gear buy a tripod buy microphone and
camera and all that stuff and then do it
once and hate it and and it just sits in
my closet right tons of times we get
these ideas we go and spend money and
then nothing happens with it where i
prefer to invest a lot of energy time
put my passion into something and see if
i can make money doing it and if i can i
want to keep doing it then i can invest
the money that i make into getting
better gear and growing whatever idea
this applies to anything not just making
youtube videos so when i started
i started with the gear that i had i had
a nikon camera a dslr and i just set it
up i put it on uh
i put it on a shelf and i had it point
at me and i pressed record and
went from there uh you know it had a
built-in microphone that wasn't very
good but it was a microphone and then
people complained that you know they
were too blurry and you know you
couldn't hear
hear my audio properly so
i had to have my sister or somebody on
my team come and focus it on me and
press record and then leave the room
because i couldn't have them in the room
while i was a cord and i was too nervous
and they threw me off so i had to have
them leave
and as
the audience grew and i started making
some money off of it i i got a tripod i
just went to my local
camera store and i got a tripod and i
started investing in better cameras and
i started going to costco i went to
costco because you have a longer return
policy the camera stores i think it was
like seven days or something to try out
a camera where costco was at least 30
days and so that gave me time to really
test it out see if i liked it the first
camera that i really
uh used for a long time i found myself
going through cameras quickly i buy one
and it wasn't what i needed so i
upgraded and brought that back and then
brought that one back and upgraded and i
ended up getting the highest end camera
video camera that they had at costco and
i used that for maybe
a year and a half maybe two years
i still have it here here let me pull it
out this this was it this is a uh
can we see it's actually got some it's
got some dust on it because it's hasn't
been used in a long time but it's a sony
sony handycam
i don't know what the model was the the
reason why i got this one that i really
liked was it had an external microphone
jack which means i could take a
microphone and plug it into here because
the biggest complaint i got from the
audience was
the sound wasn't great because when
you're just picking it up off the camera
it's not as good as if you have a
clip-on mic so i went to the sony store
i got a mic so
this is the mic that i've used for a
couple years it still works great it's
just a clip-on mic that i run through my
shirt cost me about 90 bucks at the time
and then i could plug it into here put
this on my tripod and
away i went and that lasted me for a
year and a half two years i was editing
the videos myself i was using movie
maker and then that's a free software
that comes with your windows computer
and it allows you to do basic stuff then
i started learning camtasia
which is more advanced and then i got to
the point where you know
my best time is focus on being on camera
i'm never going to be the world's
greatest video editor it wasn't
something i was passionate about
learning to become i wanted to be better
at speaking and i needed to delegate
that editing work so i i hired
uh i went to odesk and i hired somebody
to help edit all of the videos that went
up
so the process i used was i record
i then
um
save it to my computer put in the
dropbox folder it would send off to my
my worker on odesk and then i would get
it sent back to me the next day and
upload it to youtube
the next person i hired for my editing
started doing a lot of cool effects this
is christina now who i hired who still
does my videos hi christina and
she started doing these cool things she
would zoom in on me
and the challenge with this camera was
if you zoomed in
it reduced the quality so it's getting a
little blurry it wasn't as good quality
and i thought you know what i'm doing
better with the videos you know they're
getting me speaking gigs i'm getting
opportunities from them i need to invest
in better gear so i got rid of this well
i still have it but i don't use it
anymore and i got let me get the book
this so this is what i use now it's a
canon xa10 it was such a crazy world you
know when i was trying to figure out
what video to go with i was overwhelmed
there's so many options out there it's
like i just want something that i can
put in press record it'll be awesome on
automatic and and i'm good because i
don't want to spend all this time
figuring out what camera to go with so i
um connected with a buddy of mine named
mark drager who runs a company called
phantom media and he was getting a
little
upset at me because
he wanted to show me how to use all the
manual settings and to make the videos
really good you have to really you know
set the the settings properly and
understand the lighting and like oh man
i don't want any of that give me a
camera that that is really good on
automatic
that will give me good quality when
christina zooms in on me
zooms in on me
and
and that's it and that's all i wanted
and so he recommended this camera to me
i bought it and so it cost me around two
thousand dollars so my whole setup now
camera is about two thousand dollars
tripod is maybe 75 bucks the microphone
is
90 bucks
uh the old camera that was maybe 300
bucks so it's not a huge investment to
get from costco maybe a little bit more
maybe 500 bucks but still not a huge
investment and then as i stepped up
every time as i got more money as i got
more confidence i got more feedback as i
wanted to make them better i invested
more because i could so i always focus
on making money and i can go out and
spend it in terms of the process of
editing them what happens now is again i
want my focus to be on making the videos
so i started doing everything myself
creating the videos editing cutting
intro extra i created my own music and
my ipad doing it
and now all i really do is film i come
here
i see your question i press record i
start talking i film it put it to my
computer and i send it to christina and
that's the last i see of it she will
edit it at the intro the music the extro
any fun clips that i put in and then she
will upload it to my youtube channel
schedule it
so she does all of that work awesome
thank you christina and that's the
process i use so i would encourage you
if you're just getting started on
youtube you want your videos to be
successful start with what you have
right don't don't feel like you have to
go out and and go buy the greatest gear
start with your phone
i made videos off my phone that i've
gotten great results as well just start
start because you're gonna suck at the
start and you need to get better and
improve and if you see results and
you're getting momentum and you're
getting clients you're getting business
and you're growing because of it then
you could invest more into making your
gear better
believe thanks for the great question if
you guys like this video want to see
more like it you can subscribe to the
channel and i will see you soon
you